whether you were in downtown ottawa or
watching from a distance
the rally cry has become the it slogan
of the so-called freedom convoy with
pierre pollierev even using it to
announce he's running as conservative
leader freedom to make your own health
and vaccine choices an expert on u.s and
canadian politics says it's not a
coincidence it's one of those terms in
politics that everyone is for regardless
of where they stand politically
much like democracy a term that is now
being used for more nefarious reasons
barbara perry studies hate bias and
extremism she says the us influence here
is pretty clear it follows on the uh the
american protests that we've been seeing
you know leading up to the trump
election and after the the trump
election as well it has absolutely
become a rallying cry but
certainly been exploited by the far
right in particular
and reinterpreted perhaps
and given different meaning but trump is
not the only one to blame goodman says
other slogans were borrowed from farther
borders take back america for instance
sounds a lot like take back control from
brexit it means we're seeing an
international influence in slogans
thanks to social media traditional
barriers to language use
that used to
be held up by national borders have
started to fade or become more permeable
since the internet language travel is
common kelly wright says but it was the
broadness of the term freedom that has
also made it such a hit
linguists even have a name for the
phenomenon under specification there's
some really interesting
usefulness in
having like something be under specified
it's really just about mobilizing people
towards whatever end you would like to
point them words are absolutely weapons
uh drawn in a conflict goodman says
those using the word freedom should be
very specific in their pleas take it
back from who and take it back for who
and take it back to do what with it
meanwhile the public should continue to
use the word in constructive ways like
fighting for social progress or risk
losing it to the far right ibrahim
global news